one does not simply buy any random mouse
in 2021. do you go with razer logitech
zowie steel series or some custom
designer hypebeast nonsense that looks
like it was made for a 14 year old
fortnite obsessed thor do i want wired
or wireless oh and don't forget side
buttons you need side buttons and why in
the holy hell do they have all of these
well holes in them well the answer to
all of these questions might be simpler
than you think a few years ago logitech
set out to create the perfect mouse a
product that no matter what esport you
play would sit atop all other gaming
mice and for the most part they
succeeded the g-pro has become maybe the
most ubiquitous gaming peripheral in the
world but
it's not perfect it's staggering price
point and alleged propensity for double
clicking make it not only the most
popular mouse out there
but also the most enigmatic
and that begs the ultimate question
is it worth it
all right so way back in 2017 logitech
began development on their g-pro
wireless mouse this was supposed to be
the one mouse to rule them all a mouse
that regardless of the genre of game you
played could be used at the highest
level so with this in mind they decided
to ask the people who mattered most what
they wanted out of the mouse
the pros the pro wireless gaming mouse
is a huge innovation for us it's the
first time we've made a pro product from
the ground up starting from nothing we
worked with the pros said we had over 50
pros that we worked with and we started
with the question what do you want
in a pro wireless gaming house players
from fps games and even mobas united to
give logitech some feedback to help with
the design process of the mouse and at
the top of everyone's list was latency
before the development process of any of
logitech's g series mice it wasn't
really a secret that wireless mice
weren't really an upgrade from wired per
se
mostly because they didn't really work
very well for years wireless mice were
plagued by latency issues and nobody
wanted to use them for gaming if you're
playing games at the highest level of
competition there's no way in hell you
want a laggy mouse pro players just
couldn't trust them so to combat this
issue logitech developed lightspeed
lightspeed as a technology has
fundamentally changed the game in terms
of
what is possible on the pro stage now
logitech claimed that their new light
speed technology offered a one
millisecond response time a speed so
fast that it could potentially be more
responsive than some wired mice now some
people were skeptical of this naturally
but as it turns out
logitech wasn't kidding tech review
channels like linus tech tips were
pretty quick to confirm that gaming mice
using lightspeed do in fact respond
faster than some wired mice and although
they weren't able to physically test the
transmission time they did confirm that
there is no noticeable difference
between a wired mouse and a mouse using
logitech's wireless light speed
technology what we can take away from
our experiment is that at least for
logitech we have validated their
position that anyone who claims to be
able to tell the difference between
their wired and wireless mice is either
imagining it or full of
and that is all that the world of
esports needed to hear not to mention
the fact that according to logitech the
g-pro boasted 48 hours of battery life
with the rgb lighting on and 60 hours
with the lighting off and that you could
charge it back to full in just two hours
so with all of this good stuff to say
about the g pro and its performance it
begs the question why would you use
anything else well that's what's so
interesting about mice while this
lightweight wireless low latency beast
is impressive it's not guaranteed to
make you better at games mice aren't
just science there's a splash of romance
to them over time comfort trumps all and
for people like me who would die for
their zowie za11 i would rather a larger
heavier mouse with a cord strictly
because it's my mouse the g pro might be
the best for most people but that
doesn't mean it's the best for you now
despite the ultra low latency and
tremendous battery life what really
stole the show was logitech's brand new
hero sensor paired with the weight of
the mouse the logitech gpro wireless is
a medium-sized ambidextrous mouse with
modular side buttons currently the best
sensor on the market and it only weighs
about 80 grams hero is an incredible
feat of technology we have
we released it first last year about a
year ago
and we've continued to improve it since
then it's the best performing sensor on
the market right now it's the most
accurate sensor on the market it's
capable of speeds uh exceeding 400
inches per second
and it does this while consuming less
power than any other sensor on the
market all right hold up this is
starting to get a bit technical so let
me break it down for you a bit
dimitri what is a mouse sensor you can
think of a mouse sensor as a tiny
incredibly high speed digital camera the
sensor takes pictures of the surface
you're moving across and compares them
to determine speed and direction and it
does this thousands of times a second so
what makes the hero sensor so great well
obviously logitech's not going to give
up all of the secret sauce but here's a
quick rundown the sensor is
unsurprisingly fast able to capture
well-lit and highly detailed images at
pretty absurd frame rates but it's also
very power efficient able to adjust the
lighting for the sensor on a frame by
frame basis more responsive lift off
detection a fully adaptive frame rate
and highly optimized power distribution
to the different processing blocks hell
this thing is capable of capturing
movement at the sub micron level i'm
talking
0.001 millimeters
coincidentally also the odds that
dimitri beats me in a 1v1 outside of cs
or dota i mean don't forget siege
overwatch
valorent pretty much any mouse and
keyboard game that doesn't have anime
characters in it wait no scratch that i
don't even play league and i would still
smoke you in it anyway it seemed as
though logitech made what might just be
the perfect mouse a fully wireless
high-performance ambidextrous gaming
mouse with the greatest sensor on the
market and a shape that closely
resembled zowie's fabled fk1 and with a
marketing campaign that featured some of
the world's greatest esports athletes
the g-pro wireless was pretty much
destined for success but at a whopping
150 us dollars logitech was asking you
to pay what was at the time
way more than the industry standard for
a [ __ ] mouse
the question was was all of this just
one big marketing play or were actual
competitors going to use this thing at
the highest level well when players got
their hands on the mouse they actually
loved it vpro's a fantastic mouse uh but
it's it's really like once you go
wireless i feel like you really you just
really can't go back it's just a
different feeling right as the jeeper
came out i was one of the first people
to like test it because i
united the organizer was like sponsored
by logitech so they let me like try out
their mouse their new mice and i
instantly use the gpro before it was
even released ever since i've been using
it it's just felt
a lot better i mean grip is kind of like
perfect in my hand i'd say my friends
made a lot of fun because they would
always say like oh once you use a
wireless mice or a wireless mouse you
can never go back i never really
understood that until i started using a
wireless mouse and now i just feel like
i can't use any other mouse besides the
g pro more and more eyes were drawn to
the g pro when the london spitfire won
the inaugural season of the overwatch
league with their entire roster using
the mouse rainbow six siege titans like
g2 and eventually tsm were also
consistently showing their love for it
with the latter's youtube-born star
fragger bolo becoming pretty much the
most clouded and capable advocate the
most had ever seen i think when i
actually picked up the g pro initially
you know before tsm it was definitely i
guess hype based you know everybody's
talking about the wireless mouse it was
you know kind of starting to get its
recognitions like you know it's finally
a wireless mouse that you can actually
use without you know i know i know
everybody was talking about like input
lag and or delay i think it definitely
lived up to it you know
cloud or not it was pretty it pretty
competitive with all other mice and on
top of it it was wireless so i just i
think it was a really good option for a
lot of people so with plenty of pro
players standing the g pro it turned out
that people were willing to shill out
the 150 us dollars for it
but as more and more people got their
hands on the damn thing some unfortunate
souls began to unravel something tragic
their hundred and fifty dollar g pro
wireless
was double clicking and double clicking
has been the number one issue with g pro
wireless over the last two years i am
experiencing double clicking issues
which i already knew i probably was
going to it really sucks you know the
mouse is great but you know it kind of
ruins your consistency when you un-ads
during a gunfight now to be clear not
every g pro was susceptible to the
doubleclick issue but there were plenty
of people out there who were in
desperate need of a fix the cause of
this issue still to this day
isn't really confirmed but i can confirm
to you that it still happens because two
of my co-workers here at the score have
had it happen to them in the last year
now most people just ship the mouse back
and hope that when logitech sends them a
new one it works
but others think that at times it can
actually be user error i've definitely
experienced it sometimes especially
towards the
longer side like once i've used a mouse
for like six months or so especially in
like high pressure situations gaming you
know you panic you try to click really
hard and it ends up double clicking but
for the most part it only happens every
now and then and after the first like
you know one or two times me actually
doing that i realized that it's more or
less me clicking it too hard instead of
the mouse's issue but regardless of
whether your gpro double clicks or
doesn't double click you shouldn't have
to worry about something like this from
a hundred and fifty dollar mouse when
you're dishing out that kind of money
you expect it to just work more recently
logitech released the g pro super light
which is basically the same mouse but 20
grams lighter they've opted to use
different switches in the super light in
the hope that it will fix the double
clicking issue and so far
it seems to have worked transitioning to
the super light i have not experienced
it a single time and i was even using it
before
uh it released or was even announced i
had like a prototype version you know
because uh logitech gives out some of
them for players to try you know kind of
give some feedback so i was using a
prototype version never once experienced
on that even after launch and to this
day
i haven't experienced it i think we're
going on like nine months of using it
not a single double click on the super
light and although plenty of cs go
loving boomers such as myself refuse to
stop using our beloved zowie mice plenty
of other competitors across multiple
titles are switching to the g pro it
might just be the single most used
wireless mouse in all of esports if
anybody's using a wireless mouse it's
100 to gpro the question of course
is why what is it about the g pro that
makes it this ostensibly goated piece of
hardware is it the fact that it got
there first the fact that shroud had one
forged in his image there's this sort of
mysticism around the g pro this like
unspoken consensus that it's the be-all
and end-all of gaming mice and i'll be
honest i think a lot of it has to do
with
well
hype
the g-pro is like the yeezy of gaming
peripherals you don't really have to
like it you just have to own one if you
consider yourself an enthusiast but to
be fair the other reason that people
fanaticize over it is that it has what
you'll often hear most guru rocket jump
ninja refer to as a safe shape the g-pro
boasts a smooth versatile and altogether
inoffensive profile which lends itself
very well to pretty much any mouse grip
in any esport is the g pro god's gift to
gaming probably not
do you need one if you want to compete
at a high level
definitely not
is it a stellar mouse that essentially
changed mouse design as we know it
yes and if you like it can afford it and
it fits your hand
then buy it because even if i don't
really get the buzz around it i can't
deny that logitech accomplished what
they initially set out to do over three
years ago hell if they made it in a
larger size which as i see it is the
only real issue with the g pro
i'd probably give it a go logitech did
indeed manage to create a mouse that
just about any professional can use at
the highest level of just about any
esport and with plenty of big names
backing both the g pro and the g pro
super light it seems fair to say that
this mouse
isn't going anywhere
not to mention
what other games most
everything but halo right uh
you beat me in osu
yeah you have the you have the wii power
even though i have better aim with a
mouse you do have
the weeb power you just channel that
[ __ ] what's that what's the g pro of
controllers is that the scuff yeah i
can't wait until we do that video yo
think about the jokes that we're gonna
get to take when we do a video about a
[ __ ] controller like i don't i'm
gonna literally have no [ __ ] idea
what is happening in any of this [ __ ]
like
it's gonna be great it's gonna be so
good